fricken Safari and may include animal
kills and caucuses viewer discretion is
advised
look at the beautiful kudos at the
moment they are all just trying to
investigate about what is happening in
the surrounding what a lovely afternoon
and most of all welcome to the beginning
of the afternoon Safari this is Sydney
from Ronnie my cozy and I'm travelling
with Sansa who is my camera operator
this afternoon we are going to try by
all means and look for some cats
this afternoon as this morning it was
very much difficult by this side of the
western side of the greater Kruger
National Park Juma Game Reserve this is
an interactive life Safari you can
follow us on Twitter hashtag Safari live
you can also follow us on YouTube chat
stream
so these gurus I can see that the
feeding on something there on the ground
I just want to check nicely maybe they
must be doing this behavior of eating
some old bones now they're just feeding
on some of their small trees they I can
see that they are not specifically
feeding on any of the bones you can see
they are right there one of them it that
is the female the male Carew's they have
got horns the female kudos
they don't have horns and this males
have got very beautiful spiral horns
kudos males are one of the best
good-looking males in the world these
animals are so very huge unbelievable
same animal huge like this can be able
to jump four meters hyphens sometimes
standing from jumping from a standing
position
so now let's quickly across over to
David in the Maasai Mara who is also
about to start looking for some animals
this afternoon a very good afternoon
everyone and welcome to the Mara
triangle you were just with sit in South
Africa but now you've come to a
different country because I would first
to show you a bar this is flied as God
as gone just gone but anyhow it was bad
that echo the lilac breasted roller
which is my favorite but my name is
David and with me today is a Bunga boom
a good afternoon welcome
and since ade questions/comments more
than welcome please feel free to talk to
us on hashtag Safari live and just like
Sydney I'm also planning to go looking
for layouts this afternoon I am going
through the whole of this area and make
sure before long we'll be having some
lions with us that sounds good
well beautiful day here before afternoon
not a very hot clouds are lying a bit
low grace not
scary nothing to give us any rain but
hopefully we're gonna have a wonderful
sermon be happy just hello to all of you
too
well good afternoon everybody and
hopefully who what will lead to a very
exciting start to our day it's not very
often that you'll see me out of the
vehicle so early in the drive and
there's a very good reason for why I'm
Archer but before we get into it my name
is Justin on camera I've got to David
this afternoon and it is a good
welcome to Juma because here in the sand
is something that we see very very
little of and it's right in the center
part of Juma we on the western side of
quarantine at the moment and at the
backyard you'll notice that there's a
sort of low shape that's happened and
there's one two three four toes with
claws on the front and so for those of
you that are a little bit kind of
knowledgeable about your tracks this is
for a cheetah so there is a cheetah
somewhere on Juma that has come through
looks like sort of towards the end of
the rain last night and has walked
around here during the course of the day
it's very very badly obscured and a lot
of vehicles have driven over it but
before sure it's a cheetah track which
is incredibly interesting because
there's well not been many Chiefs has
seen on Juma for quite some time
it looks like it a female track it
doesn't look like or a very young male
but like I say the disturbance there is
huge from the rain so it's going to be
interesting to check if this cheetah is
still around it might have gone all the
way through and crossed again I
certainly have a really good scour of
this area and see if maybe just maybe we
get lucky with the cheetah
somewhere on Juma wouldn't that be a
spectacular way to have a Sunday
afternoon Drive I think so so we're
gonna try very hard to see where this
cheetah goes I want to probably check
the sort of western side and there's a
lot more open sections and areas that
are not bad for cheetah as opposed to
the more the sort of southeast the
southeast becomes a lot more kind of
liquidy in its environment there's a lot
more kind of thickets and drainage lines
whereas this western portion has a few
more clearings and openings that will be
conducive for cheetah to move around the
problem is is that there's vehicles that
have driven down this road during the
course of the day today or during the
morning drive and that's going to make
it very tricky to be able to pick up
where these
cheaters walked and at first wasn't sure
if it was a cheater when I first saw the
track I kind of um Dennard about it for
quite a while but one of the other guys
that I spoke to one of the landowners he
saw the tracks actually this morning and
he said to me there was definitely
cheetah tracks that he saw them in the
soft sand before they drove over them so
yeah it's good news in many respects
that there is a cheetah kind of hanging
around but what I'm going to do is I'm
not gonna do quarantine just yet I'm
gonna go around and do a loop around and
then we'll come back to quarantine just
now I just want to check if it didn't go
down towards kind of Impala planes
because Impala planes would be a good
place for a cheetah to hang out it's
quite interesting that there is one
moving around there was tracks for one I
believe on before hawk not yesterday the
day before coming past a dam then going
towards sort of tortured so I suppose
it's very possible that this cheetah is
angled from there onto the side and is
then kind of moved along through here
Jamie says to me though she had wild dog
tracks on a very similar kind of
trajectory so there's lots of rare and
endangered things that's moved about
during the course of the night last
night that's for sure you can see where
the guys have been turning around trying
to see where they can find these tracks
anyway and we're going to try and see
what we can find see if we get any signs
of the cheetah further along in the road
while we do that though off to Jamie you
go so she can say hello for the
afternoon
if anyone can track down a cheetah Juma
Tristan can I have utmost faith in his
cat finding ability a very good
afternoon to all of you my name is Jamie
and this afternoon
Craig is on camera with me also known of
course as a bat man but don't tell
anyone because it's something of a
secret so as you may or may not have
heard from various people this morning
was quiet on the cat / dog / hiya front
we didn't manage to find anything which
is pretty typical for this time of year
especially after a nice big storm like
that so now of course the focus becomes
trying to find something for the TV
show this evening I'm going to meander
along my plan is it was a bit
frustrating 10 Ghana was found yesterday
evening just before the rehearsal and
then he vanished into a block and the
person who found him moved off and I
didn't get there in time to switch
places and and follow him now we know
where he disappeared to but we also know
that he had last night
now if it's in Ghana not to call but
that sort of time evening is unusual
which makes me think hope perhaps force
of optimism here that he has a kill in
that direction so that's where I'm
heading the softer noon you know why I
didn't think of it this morning although
it was very very far away okay so that's
the plan anyway we're gonna hit across
in that direction while we do that
Davison the Maasai Mara which of course
comes with its own challenges that Dave
can best well good luck for King Ghana
and ting Ghana being the duke of Jummah
it's always such a big prize and I've
always thought Singh ting Ghana alone is
worth seeing maybe two other lipids
you know just virtually because of his
size and above all he's huge Dilip I've
seen many leopards in Africa but thin
ting Ghana maybe Jamie made a grave me
or Tristan and Sydney Singh Ghana has
one of the largest juleps I think we
know of all the little parts that we see
around you know Africa
so anyway talking of lions and no little
plans today or new year I'm sure some of
you might have watched ours here in the
Mara triangle I was unlucky to have seen
two leopards you know and it isn't like
Duma you knows getting sightings of
leopards in the mall is a bit difficult
to see livers as much as we've got them
here they're all over they're all over
but usually say they blend in very well
they hide in some places but you may not
be able to see them
but that particularly remains very
special to me because one it was New
Year's Day the fastest are there of 2019
and it was not only one levered there
were two and two a cherry on the cake
they were meeting and too many people in
there in North America the feedback we
got it was at the stroke of midnight
that was very special so I have been
looking at my clock from the first of
January another 1995 days hopefully if
that female conceived and you know she's
changed around will be able to see her
cub or her new Cubs I mean unlike other
cuts like cheetahs that may move long
distances all that do not have a
territories leopards and lions yes are
will have children yes to be very good
am as she says in the front of control
to have newly you know babies that were
conceived all the Nui are thought to be
very special well today I want to look
for one particular bright defy the tag
called the sausage surprise because it's
my favorite fried in the morrow he got
loads of lion fights but that particular
one it's my favorite the area we are
going through a little bit father
another watch five kilometers or so or
seven is an area we should see another
pride but is called a or we know or we
know is four girls and one male and I
think originally if that pride of we
know used to be the same pride with the
sausages then this place sometimes in
the 2016 and they went separate ways
when Lions or when price gets very big
they tend to split not very far for the
camp where we live in there's another
play there that is called ole ole
applied and all our currently at 16 and
I got a feeling that chill of the
females there have given birth and maybe
we have either two more new Cubs or four
new Cubs and that figure might soon rise
to 20 well as a given point 24 the area
they live in will be too large and
chances are the mates also stress very
good so let's all work very hard let's
make sure we get lie on to this
afternoon and I'm sure our Sydney is
doing the same
I am working hard now I am somewhere
around the buffers hook them I'm trying
to check if maybe I can find those liens
the ones we saw yesterday the mating
pairs the two couples were in this area
yesterday and since the rain they got
disappeared
they haven't been spotted yet since
yesterday so after the rain they went
maybe they went to the buffers look as
from yet buffers with just about five
minutes the mating pairs that is quite a
lovely question mating pairs on these
layers they can stay together for about
seven days and more less than two weeks
and in that seven consecutive days
they've got to be mating four times
approximately an hour that is quite a
responsibility so that is why sometimes
lions are mating they lose quite a lot
of body condition they become thin
especially if the female went on heat
before they eat something then it
becomes a challenge because the male
doesn't want to go and interact with the
other males where the food is so they
always isolate each other for mating so
they lose body condition and look very
much pain
so but the one woman female and the one
Avoca we're lucky because they have met
during the feeding on the buffalo so
they ate and after that they went for
mating and it started there so we are
still going to see them for a while
because this meeting started three days
ago
so the steers got a display of got a
long way to go
so I'm just trying to check some tracks
here around the Guara pen this is more
or less the same kind of an area we left
them yesterday so far there are no
tracks here at all so we are going to
expect a lot of babies it means add more
or less the same kind of month we might
have babies from both females because
all these females they started meeting
at the same day
so now let's quickly cross over to a man
from far David with the Lions
well Sydney keep looking keep looking
because there is by getting some trucks
that will lead you to something
interesting now there's one major
difference between the Mara triangle and
juma in terms of vegetation the morrow
is open it is vast and you can spot an
animal from like what sometimes 5
kilometers not every animal I'm not
talking of ants or earthworms and took
your big game for example elephants
because you do not need to get your
follow because to sport some elephants
you just need to open your eyes and open
them hard and you'll end up with some
Ellie's that's one of the differences
between where we are and Duma in terms
of the disability good afternoon
more ladies than gentlemen I would say
because in Elise or in herds of
elephants ideally you see more girls and
maybe with the young ones and very few
if any males unless of course there's a
bit of a meeting going on so in heart
like this out maybe think all of these
are girls and some youngsters and of
course the youngsters could be either
both boys or girls one massive female
that I'm guessing that one is a female
she is huge by any standard I mean look
at her Jenny could we ever do bush
walking tomorrow yes it's doable but I
think it has never been tried and I
think the management thinks is a bit
dangerous but maybe one day they might
do it but we do not do any bush walks
here and what I think Jenny I was just
talking a few minutes ago that there's a
huge difference in terms of vegetation
or the habitat between where we are and
Juma in the sense that here you see
animals from a long long way so should
you see elephants out guess it could be
a bit tricky and elephants can easily
come and find you you know why you
aren't right just trying to guess but
Jenny we have not done any bush walks
here and maybe one day and when you ask
the authorities they like while they
have their own reasons but it's also
possible with proper planning and with
the proper training because guys are
trained and they're always just in kids
carry a gun for protocol they know areas
to go how to read the body language of
animals how to look at trucks so maybe
one day but as it is now the new bush
walks that are done in the Mara hello
there you can see the difference in
terms of habitats as I was saying
earlier the openness or the vastness of
the Mara you can see all the way to the
horizon the only visual pollution they
got now are these elephants and the
trees in the background there but you
can see all the way to the sky and
you're not a very high elevation I'm
talking about 2,000 meters where I am
now you know give or take 5,000 feet
above sea level but it all looks plain
or flat kind of a hundred eighty degrees
pretty young ones there some Cubs trying
to feed on that particular bush it
definitely there's something they
enjoying in that particular thicket
child of the universe always got to good
hear your name well then no one no there
no particular animals would see each
other the universe in the Mara that will
have a particular season together with
for example elephants child of the
universe they breed all around the
Rhinos the same buffalos the same some
turkey lows have the large animals that
will think of buffalos elephants rhinos
they will like be breeding or meeting or
having the Cubs in charge of the
universe all around am so the only other
animals I would think that could have a
particular period to have the young ones
are the wildebeest but of course those
ones would get the young ones in
Serengeti National Park or the Western
Gordon borough conservation area in
Tanzania
well elephants very good entertaining us
we need to move and we also need to
take you to South Africa to my friend
Tristan well indeed and so we're not
with a cheetah but there you will see
dangling in the bowels of a tree is a
carcass now unfortunately that caucus is
not on our side of the road it's sitting
in a inside tortured at the moment and
we can't go in there but we think that
that carcass might be for husana we not
actually weren't even on our way to him
we're trying to get to Chitra to try and
follow up on a report that some civility
is around and we kind of came across a
carcass in the tree and so apparently
the guys say to me who you've gone there
now that's
hasanah might it be the one that's the
I'm just trying to see if I can get a
view of any leopard actually at the tree
itself but let's see there's the kind of
base of the tree David can you see
anything I see a tail there's a tail
there yes there's a head in a tail so if
anybody can ID our lipid from that then
good luck hopefully you can and you'll
be able to pick up and I would say
husana it is hasana there we go he's
turned his head so there's no sonic at
hello boy there's lots and lots of
vultures around so I wonder if he didn't
steal this from something but there is
husana he's unfortunately deep and
tortured and there's gonna be a lot of
cars that want to go there so we're not
gonna stay with him too long but
interesting that he is there
that's definitely kind of good news at
least he's got himself a meal and now we
know where he's been hanging out which
is down here on the sort of south west
and but I'm sorry the eastern boundary
and kind of just north of chitra dam is
pretty much where we are at the moment
and it explains why he's been absent but
he's definitely got a carcass it's not a
very big carcass and so he'll be a happy
boy the problem is is that they were
lots of vultures when we first got here
now typically carcass in a tree is not
something that attracts vultures all
that easily and so I'm wonder if he
maybe didn't get this carcass from
somewhere else and he's stolen it you
know there's been a lot of wild dogs
around and those kind of things often
they'll leave bits of a carcass and that
attracts vultures and that's maybe why
he's found
caucus I don't know but Carroll you say
everyone's been very worried about him
yes it's never nice when we don't see a
sauna for a few days so it's really nice
that we saw him at least the albeit very
very far away and very brief at least
we've managed to kind of get some sort
of visual of him and if he goes up into
the tree it would actually not be too
bad but you can see look at his belly is
huge so he's been sitting on food for
quite some time he's been eating a lot
and I don't know if this carcass is it
and he's just kind of been eating this
one oh man maybe he managed to find this
carcass today and has been sitting on a
different carcass through the course of
the last few days so it's interesting
either way his tummy is absolutely
massive so it's gonna be interesting to
see what happens now entreatingly enough
sabri and cub like I say are some way in
the Melua knee knee which from here to
where husana is is all about I would say
maybe 300 meters 400 meters and it's
gonna be intriguing to see if asana
actually heads that direction it's gonna
be very very interesting but he's kind
of just lay down at the moment so we're
gonna carry on we're gonna leave him
there unfortunately there's two other
cars that are coming in this direction
so maybe if a little bit later if he's
up in the tree we'll come back and kind
of spend some time with him but very
cool to see you sana I'm very glad to
see him will be it's not very nice
visual Sonoran tea Hosanna you need to
come back this way and then maybe we'll
get lucky
in the meantime Burt let's send you back
across to Sydney who I'm sure will be
happy to hear that things are starting
to change and maybe our luck will change
and his luck will change too
congratulations to Tristan for finding
you host I ain't seen him for quite a
long time now I am still around here but
the buffers hook area checking around
this day I am now checking the northern
part of the dam to see if maybe we can
find these lions and I am sometimes even
stopping and killing the engine so that
I can hear if there is any of their
mating rituals taking place very much
quiet at the moment
yeah but the Lions when they are mating
they take a little bit of nap wake up
and carry on so maybe there are
somewhere here just having a nap I I
didn't get you if you can repeat that
that
sigh that is quite a very very important
question and is one of the interesting
questions so let me explain this in full
the ostrich cycle of the female has got
nothing to do with the presence of a
male this is how it works the female
when the air condition is right due to
some of the ostrich and hormones she
goes on oestrus and she can be on
ostrich when the male is not there if he
is around then is lucky to detect
oestrus at early stage as these Lions
females are walking around is when they
will meet these males and then mostly
the females when they excited they
approach the males and the males will
come and confirm by sniffing the
genitals of the females and detect if
she is ready for mating sometimes they
merge themselves can also drive and
female female to go on oestrus and the
following condition when the female has
got the Cubs after a fight with a new
male of the dominant male when fighting
an intruder if the intruder with the
fight we have seen a lot doing what is
called - infanticide killing the baby of
the previous male when the female sees
the baby's dead that gives the female a
lot of stress female lions under stress
the oestrogen hormone gives a lot of
more in order to drive the female back
into austra so that the male can start
their own generation
so sometimes males can drive the female
to go on horses
so but the the mating pairs we saw
there's oestrus they all took place and
a normal condition so now while I am
still searching for the Lions let's
quickly go back to the fully belly to
asana
well it's not Hosanna Sydney we've
proven a few hundred meters cat sitting
under the tree so this is not civilian
cab either you are also again not even
100 meters from where we are so there's
four leopards seemingly in a row here
now it looks like Columba to me I
haven't really got a good look yet and I
haven't been able to look with my
binoculars property and so you guys
would have got a good shot there with
the camera and so I would have I wasn't
sure
when we first caught you and then I
bumped into somebody that I haven't seen
in many many many years that was
actually at Sangeeta when I was training
there so I had a quick chat to him as we
bumped into this leopard and then so I
haven't actually had a chance to even ID
who it is but I think clamber is who it
looks like which makes me wonder if
maybe that kill in the tree was not
Tandy's and Columba's and maybe hosana
has come in and found it due to the
vultures being around but you can see
there she's sitting she's gonna hit kind
of side and I can use my binders to have
a little look at that spot button is
that you go you've gotten quite big if
it is you it looks like you so it's
crazy there's just cats everywhere at
this stage of the afternoon lots and
lots of spotty bums but all in the wrong
places so this is in height once again
inside tortured which is not really
ideal I don't see any sign of Tandy at
the moment you can see there's a few
vultures there so I wonder if maybe
there's more of a kill somewhere in this
side and maybe that's kind of what's
going on but interesting to see
Michelle vyas very possible I mean you
misunderstand if Tandy killed the day
before and then she kind of finished
that up and came down here and killed
again if Colombo ate a little bit she
ate a bird and in husana rocked up and
ate as much as he looks like he's eaten
then it's very possible that that could
have been you know it's could have been
what's that now 24 hours 36 hours so
it's a lot of food but there has been
eaten but you know these cats can put
away quite a bit so it's interesting to
kind of figure out exactly what happened
but the way that Columbus sitting as
close as she is to where husana was
makes me think that potentially Tandy
had to kill or she's also been attracted
to the vultures much like you know
predators are they often do come and
kind of get curious with vultures and
they'll come and try and investigate
what's going on and what's happening and
try and kind of see how everything's
going but it amazes me that we've got
like I say Sibley and cub Columba and
Hosanna within a very small sort of
space now Serbian Cup is gonna be an
interesting one because they're not
going to be very happy about seeing
Columba she's gonna have to be very
careful with Sibley being around she
would not want to tangle with her
vasanas not a problem because he's bulky
enough to take care of himself even with
the likes of Sibley and so it's gonna be
an interesting kind of evening that's
going to play out hopefully you know
little Columba actually hits north it's
not good for us and if she moves
northwards but and in terms of the kind
of way things go it would be better in
the long run if she went away from where
Sibley is it's gonna be an interesting
afternoon that's for sure I wonder if
asana will be kind of brave enough to
leave his kill and wander down towards
the Maloney need to come and investigate
what's going on down here and bump into
all of these leopards on the side but
from no lipids to lots
returned Monique you say did I cover
myself in catnip once again so no I
didn't I was actually to be honest with
you there's quite worried about this
afternoon because we obviously have our
TV show and we had nothing this morning
and but kind of Concerned as to where
everybody is but it seems as though
everyone decided to have a party on the
main road close to chitwa and so it was
worthwhile kind of just coming down and
seeing what's going on this side the
thing is is that you know there's
obviously been kind of some interaction
between Easley episod I don't think that
they can all be in the same place at
once
with this many vultures without anybody
kind of realizing that there's a liquid
here so I think they've all kind of come
in for the same reason and I wouldn't be
surprised if there's another lipid
behind us
hello Dundee so there's Tandy behind us
I think it's Dundee behind us yes there
comes Columbo that's very very cool
so there's actually five lipids in the
space of I don't even it's not even 500
meters that these five cats and you can
see their tummies are full so I think
they were on that kill as well but how
awesome is this to have time the entry
number and hopefully they're gonna move
into chuckler because that will allow us
to be able to follow them so we're just
gonna turn around so we can actually see
them hello Tandy
it's exciting there's a cool if they got
another kill they looks like it they do
so they've got another kill here so
there's actually three kills in the
space of 500 meters by the looks of
things so you can see there's another
kill right there David can you've got a
good line of shots but Ricky with her
face but there we go there's another
carcass right over there which is
absolutely crazy so we've got what's not
on the kill these two wanna kill and
sabri and cub wanna kill down in the
Malloy and Nene so three different
leopard kills in five hundred meters
which is pretty insane any way that you
look at it but good fast this it's good
news it means that you know we've got at
like at least lots going on in the
course of this evening but what it also
means is that maybe Sydney wants to come
and head down towards Chitra I'm not
sure if it's possible of tech wise
forget these things these days but if he
wants to maybe head down towards Chitra
and he can kind of come and maybe go to
one of the other lipids I think that
would be a probably a good idea given
that we're not gonna be able to cover
all of these by ourselves and I'm sure
you guys want to see Sabri in cub - I
don't think the Cubs ever been seen on
any of our live drives so it would be
nice if she was also kind of put on
camera at some point but either way very
very cool
kind of a afternoon that's developed out
of absolutely no way and it's blustery
kind of conditions and I thought we can
have it really kind of tough afternoon
to be able to see you know tani and
Colombo and Hassan and have all of these
cats come out as has been pretty insane
so I'm very very lucky at this stage
the only problem with a sighting like
this in this particular areas that it's
going to be a complete fun fight because
there's going to be cars going up and
down and being on the main road
it's obviously going to be a bit tricky
there's gonna be a lot of people kind of
moving on and so what I hope that's
gonna happen is Tunney's actually gonna
move this deep into chitwa or and that
will just kind of make everything a
little bit more sort of settled as we
have as many cars but how cool is this
I'm so happy right now that we managed
to find these two you I kind of driving
along going down towards where we
thought Sibley was and kind of there was
a little alum but just sitting on the
side of the road and I actually didn't
even look to my right because I spotted
her first and I must have just driven
straight past Tandy which she probably
did not enjoy at all yeah very cool
though but we might just reposition
ourselves and just get into a bit of
spots while we do that though let's send
you back up to the Maasai Mara and David
who I think is on in the search for his
sausages and hopefully with some luck
he'll manage to find them by the end of
the evening we left the elephants kept
moving on heading towards the area I'm
hoping to get some lions today but of
course although as usual along the way
you meet a lot of traffic and you have
found this traffic of Ellen's the
largest antelopes that we got in Africa
huge and my guess is the males it seemed
like to be four boys massive in size
howl is a little bit bigger and then the
females in terms of horns and body
morphology and everything else now when
we took off my aggression will always
talk of wildebeest zebras but also we
got have a small percentage of the
migration that consists of this antelope
SIA that I could announce and one of it
or the one you see on the back and this
aboard the train either to get some
ticks or mites to birds actually from
its body you'll get most of these
herbivores being happy you know
inhabited by ticks or mites and these
bars that you call ox because
we'll always help them or remove them in
a kind of relationship that you called
symbiosis or a submerged relationship
and the two types of walk speakers at
the red-billed or the yellow-billed
oxpeckers now my guess is these are for
boys here there isn't a single cow males
in general being begins residency
regression color
it's a massive julep till half was the
one in the front a young male you could
be a little younger than the other four
well we will just have to move a little
bit so that we make it to our
destination where I'm hoping to go and
get the Lions all right
wonderful light at the moment just
looking nice feels very very good and in
the kind of grass you have now I will
not be surprised to sport something from
a distance and comfortably I'll be able
to pick whatever I see excellent just
friends of ours who are just moving are
they are very good hooked up to you very
good very good let's go back to Tristan
and see how it looks like
yes we're still sitting at these two
naam while we've been kind of off a I've
been trying to chat to everybody and
there's obviously mass confusion because
everyone thought this was subway in cab
and obviously you quite clearly it's
quite clearly it's not it's Tandy and
clamber and so everyone was a little bit
our forts it would be odd for those two
to be this close to these two and not be
any sort of altercation what was going
on like 100 metres between those two
cats given that we know Tandy and sub we
have already fought before would be very
odd and this position forcibly would be
strange he's never come up this far and
to drag a cub this way would have been
quite interesting so it's a little bit
of a mystery solved it's tangent column
and not so we that are kind of in this
area but it's really good news for us
because you know you can see she's got a
substantial meal it's gonna probably
keep her here for most of the afternoon
the problem is the hyenas will
eventually come and they will you know
basically if she doesn't get it up into
a tree it's gonna be a bit of a problem
the other thing is is that she hasn't
chosen in you Enya a nice tree if she
goes up the tree that she's in
I don't think we'll even see her there's
so much kind of vegetation around it and
it's a pity because there's so many nice
marilla's just to the back from where
she is and would have been so nice to
kind of see money not as far as we know
so boys Cubs theoretically should have
been fathered potentially by this this
unknown male that's kind of been hanging
around little Gauri vessels the one
that's has been who sorts I think was
Taylor was it or somebody got a visual
of him one day and so he's around and we
think it's him all potentially may be a
male from Walla Walla but quarantine
could be an outsider but I don't think
ting Ghana there was no ever there was
never a sign of him mating with her and
he didn't really go down much at all but
now you can see little Columba she's
trying to kind of be submissive and
playful and she's trying to almost show
off to tandy to try and kind of let her
feed on this impala but Annie's having
nothing
she's eating as much as she can and is
really kind of going to town what I
wonder is maybe if this
particularly in parlor maybe didn't get
killed and had a little baby inside and
maybe Hassan has gotten the baby and
Tandy and Columbo have got in this part
of it it's interesting because they're
just too close for them not to have
known about each other
leopards are very very perceptive
they'll watch birds of prey they'll
smell things and the way the wind is
blowing this wind is pushing straight to
where Tandy antler lumber oh I mean
where husana has been so they should
know about each other making here she's
getting upset Tandy she's hissing and
growling while trying to eat at the same
time it can't be easy to have a hooligan
child like Columba she's got a were cut
out we know over the past year and a bit
it's taken a lot of effort to sort out
Tandy Elam and kind of keep her safe let
go so nice to see right now our day is
infinitely gotten better with a lot of
spots but it's also some tawny cats that
have Pierre done creeped out of the
woodwork and Jaime's managed to find
them don't even think about it my boy ah
No
I'm gonna sit very still
I will move back from him when I can
okay my boy
okay
I'll explain everything in a second
okay all right I'm gonna move back from
you in a sec
slowly
that's it lie down near we go okay okay
okay
all right I'm gonna move very very
slowly uh-huh
very sad words this is the skittish VOCA
male presumably sorry I couldn't take my
eyes off him for a second there because
there is a very good chance that he was
going to come at the car cool
just occur I didn't park on top of
already when we drove in he was a bit
unhappy but when then obviously when the
female walked towards us there was
nothing I could do I couldn't move then
because that aggression while he was
about to mate with her would have
provoked him so all we're doing is we
the space here oh did you get that shot
of him hissing at us awesome I wish I
had my camera
very cool very very cool okay cool so we
settled down a nice comfortable distance
the females going to keep doing that to
us which is well I mean we've got cats
coming out of our ears now I mean I know
these were the Lions that Sydney was
looking for we were looking for 10 Ghana
but we've stumbled upon them instead if
anybody says to you that the feeling of
a Lions growl doesn't travel through
their chest and they're lying to you
it does and it has a kick start straight
to your adrenal gland whether or not you
want to admit it lots of people have
been in the bush for many years and will
refuse to concede that but they're wrong
it does right I apologize for the
breakup apparently every time we move
our vehicle it causes a few issues which
of course is par for the course that's
ok well probably the correct decision
here is for me to go home and for Sydney
to make his way in because if they move
further into the straining or if they
move around like that then we will have
to move with them so if we're having a
problem while we're moving I think Em's
yeah ah ok all right well we'll figure
this all out as we go along
and so Sydney it is apparently with
Tandy now we're playing we're playing
swap the Lions round cats round yes no
it's not Sydney Jamie it is with me but
anyway what you don't often see is that
as what I was about to say is tulip it's
feeding on a carcass at once and you can
see why they don't like it when it's not
like lions or alliance or often feed on
the carcass at the same time lipids are
not like that they generally get a
little bit upset if somebody else is
feeding on the exact same
as what they are answered Columba's kind
of pushing her luck a little bit she's
managed to find herself a little snack
there that she's going to kind of feed
off and try and get but these two cats
are absolutely full full full enough to
making a kill two days ago we were
talking about it just now would they be
able to make another kill well most
definitely and as you can see there it's
a rather large kill - now what is Tandy
doing she's almost dragging it along and
he's going to feed off it the Sun maybe
she's just prepping just so that it's
close enough to a tree that if she needs
to get it up she can I mean that's going
to be a heavy carcass for her the
chances of her keeping this during the
course of the night is going to be quite
tricky and yes I made a lot of
aggression today everybody's getting a
little bit grumpy with one another hello
little fella number what are you doing
she's such a funny cat this as well how
cool is this the absolutely awesome to
have these two cats here together I'm so
glad that they are around it's lovely to
kind of be able to find them and spend
time with them the problem is is that
we're not gonna be able to spend much
time with him here unfortunately now
there's many many many many cars that
want to come through the sighting and so
given that we would like to have them a
little bit later we're probably going to
make some space just now I'm gonna allow
everybody else to rotate through and
then we can come back a little bit more
in the evening so Jenny while dogs are
most difficult it's a leopards that's
very cool to see to leopards feeding off
a carcass it's not very often that
you'll get that at the same time like I
say they very seldom all tolerates one
another feeding it's just lucky that
this carcass is so stretched that
they're actually doing it but back to
the question it's a while dogs can be
dangerous to lipids for sure both can be
dangerous to one another it depends
obviously on the circumstance and
numbers and so if you know an adult male
that comes across a puppy or something
like a dog it's going to be able to kill
it but like there is 18 dogs we saw the
other day would be a major threat to
leopards and your final epidural try and
get up into a tree as quick as possible
in order to try and get away and to try
I'm for move often trying to sort of
establish themselves as you know get
away from that kind of area I mean a nap
into a tree and stay as safe as possible
so you know it's it's one of those kind
of things in the way it kind of works is
that they'll often try and now we've got
a tug of war between mom and daughter
look you silly cats
well you can see Tandy is much stronger
than Columbus go I don't know what what
she was thinking that little fella
thought she might be able to pull mom
back but he certainly tried for a little
bit didn't she you would like your
cousin your brother should I say who saw
a half-brother absolutely clowns cats
but she's so much fun to watch I've
believed in lots of you enjoyed that
verily I did you as well right now like
I said unfortunately we are gonna have
to make space and is a lineup that is
longer than the number of fingers on my
digit on my hands and so I'm going to
have to kind of give up a spot and just
let other people come through like I
said we'll come back later once we went
sort of leave it until too late we'll
come back before the end of drive but
while we do that let's send you back
across to David in the Masai Mara see if
he's had any luck on his side hopefully
he does because it seems as though the
tables are turning and slowly but surely
luck is starting to come my way how
exciting to see Lopez II know and
especially to see such a young star
elect a lumber plane now I remember a
few days ago we were having a little
poll on Cubs of all sorts of cuts we
think of cheetahs leopards and lions and
we're asking the viewers quit on the
think is most entertaining in play
I think majority of the people agreed
that leopard cubs are the sweetest and I
think that is true and initially we
started the poll amongst ourselves I
think those between myself and Christian
and to Sydney and we started lions and
leopards and three of us in unison
agreed
perhaps more fun which I think should be
the case well I was saying alia we will
show two leopards meeting here at the
beginning of the year and hopefully if
we're gonna have our own Cubs in the
Mara we shall see a new or Kenyan to
Lambeau playing maybe by the end of
March or early April who knows I'm
almost getting to the area I call the
sausage republic and I have given it
that particular name because the pride
of lions around here defend this
territory with your teeth you know with
your clothes with your might and they do
not allow any other lions lionesses
around here not only do they fight other
lionesses oh you know they also fight
other predators like hyenas so should a
hyena come here just by mistake and
threat crisco this area the sausages
will always do a very quick piece of
work to get them out of this area well I
think Jamie got more interesting
predators than myself would go back to
her and of course they chose to mate
writer behind the call once again quite
an enthusiastic mating this and by that
I don't mean you know the the 30 seconds
or so that the actual act taste takes I
just mean that the frequency with which
they're mating is quite impressive
we know that it's early days because
apparently they were on a buffalo kill
two days ago it was only yesterday that
they started mating and they're
obviously really going into the full
sort of cycle of her Easter snow so he's
very very possessive of her which is
partly why the combination of the fact
that he's not entirely relaxed with
vehicles and the fact that well he's
mating combined to make a slightly more
aggressive lion aggressive is the wrong
word really that implies some sort of
fault
well city's coming Syd he's arriving at
the speed of light everyone I could hear
him oh I can hear him coming from my
goodness here he comes
high-speed Sydney speedy Sydney he needs
a name awesome here he comes
cool alrighty we're going to guide
Sydney in he is enthusiastically making
his way towards us let us send you a
cross to David while we do that to see
what he has to say yes or no saying you
know the sausages also did not only
fight other lions that should come to
this area and especially females but
they also fight other predators like
Highness so this is the reason or what's
the reason why I call this area the
control it's and there's no any other
Lions we have seen come here the only
thing or the only power the top is to
cause the coalition of West ideally I'm
sure you're in the Lions Kingdom then
else we'll always decide who will be
meeting with who or who will be Hoya but
ideally the females make sure no other
females come around well we have heard
before the current tumors that have been
made to the sausages that I called the
old Anya Pike to youngster third column
or two males before them there was
another coalition of males and was one
dominant whether 2spooky bully who
joined most likely our two youngsters
from our this particular pride and they
formed a coalition now it has been some
time we haven't seen them we do not know
where they are and I think the two boys
now of the old owner Pike are the
reigning champions of this particular
territory
yesterday we so the sausages had brought
down a buffalo
and a male Buffalo which was very good
of it and I feel right Freid of the
Freid
capable of dream a steep terrain
I think to me is a very but of course
there to love following and one of them
is called a king tell King still has
bent on hotel but as they try to find
out where they could be today we'll take
you back to Sydney in South Africa so
you can see the pause that we are right
now with the mating pack
just taking it over at the moment all
the credits for this afternoon with
these liens goes to Jamie is the one who
found them and congratulations to her
so you can see that the mating continues
as we left them yesterday so they they
are going to have a very busy week so
now you can see that the mail is right
there he doesn't want to hear anything
he doesn't want to move away from this
female and this is normally this is
normal
every time the male has got a female
they become so very much protective and
sometimes they are even active and
they're even much more aggressive
against also the vehicles coming to have
a sighting oh this is the same one we
were with yesterday can see the smiley I
saw that
so when the female is starting to wave
wave details a lot is when she's gonna
wake up and ask him to come and carry on
with his responsibilities can see this
male looks very beautiful
but look at all those clash marks you
can see that he has been fighting a lot
they are focused they are not that very
much old they're just now close to four
years or about four years but if you
look at the scratch marks you can see
that he has been really fighting for a
dominance
most of the time so it's good that the
other brother who is together with him
is also having a companion
so you can see now you can see that it's
lions are just very very much relaxed as
I have indicators see they the female is
starting to wave the tail they can see
the tussle of the tail
magic juggle with that this is a sleep
indeed you can see that these clowns
they look very tired but at least we
know the reason why they are so very
much tired but apart from this kind of
responsibility is normal this kind of
big cats during the day they prefers to
sleep but now the weather is changing I
can see that is becoming overcast and
when it's overcast the temperature when
is is slow the Lions they do start
walking around but at the moment there's
no need for this - to walk around
because they are mating but those who
are not part of any mating activities is
the ones who are now encouraged by this
kind of weather for them to go out and
do some hunting
Kathy and it's very much young to have
this kind of scars why am I saying this
because if these kind of liens are just
now about a focus just now above four
years old when this kind of animals
reached four years is when they are
reaching the right level of maturity
some of them they start to mate when
they're four some even more than five
that is determined by the strength and
competition in the area so this kind of
scars on this kind of a aged animal I
think is too much at this stage so this
is what we expect when is much older
than these
you can see that the main day's bald a
little bit it's moving the ears all the
time
so now let's quickly across over to
david by the masai mara who's got
something very interesting my feather
friend is one of the most unique mods
you'll see in africa because actually
these but here it is an eagle and we
call her the secretary bird because she
will always spend most of her time on
the ground that's why i'm saying she is
unique and i'm sure we all know egos
will be up in the air patched up on
trees and I would say not exactly an
eagle but she is very closely related to
egos and this is the secretary bad and
bad it's into a hunter's bad that's why
they call it secret robot which is a
friend say crop ssin of Arabic secretary
you always get them on the ground while
they'll be looking for prey of all sorts
you might think of and they do a lot of
cannibals I'm talking of them getting
grasshoppers getting locusts getting
small mammals rodents mice and once some
world you also got them catching snakes
and they used a very strong feat to you
know kill the snakes they stamp on them
as you see them they're working very
strong feet and talents they got
and in generally going to a male and a
female
not sure where the other one could be
they're very monogamous but they'll
always tend to have the nests on top of
tall trees make you see they're quite
funny-looking and especially when they
walk you know they're nothing anything
similar to like the vultures you see
they're up on that phone tree there and
I think the secretary bird was more
appealing or more beautiful than the
vultures you see on this country they
look like flowers what do you think they
look like flowers on this tree here and
a few different types of vultures yeah
African of white back to vultures I
guess and there's a good hooded vultures
and naturally we'll always think I
should vultures with kills and I
was saying earlier when I was around
this place yesterday the sausages had
brought themself down they had brought
themself some dinner for the nave for
the Nivea and they had a huge Buffalo
that they had prayed on I think the
night before last
and when I left they had eaten like
almost half of it and I guess chances
are they still have most of it left
or if finished do not have moved very
far from that particular area and seeing
these vultures here is a clear
indication that the sausages are still
there very good so I leave his fortress
and try to go to the same place I saw
the sausages yesterday and even black he
would be able to see them but let's
first go back to Sydney
so these vultures will always indicate
that there's something dead somewhere
and we will ascend with something that
somewhere then the owners of that tray
all that kill could be there and chances
are there'll be some sort of predators
now vultures to me are always associated
with big predators like lions and I'm
talking of this for those of you who are
joining us now when I talk of the
sausages is a particular pride of lions
that sleeves in this particular area and
we call it the sausage tree pride
because they've been found to climb
particular trees here in Kenya or in the
Mara triangle that I could associate
trees and they love climbing them and to
get away from the Flies if the so many
flies in the grass on the ground here or
if it's too hot and they want some
shaded area they tend to climb those
particular trees if you're lucky today
and you see those trees will tell you
why we also call them the sausage trees
because when the bear fruit the fruit
take the shape of a sausage a sausage
that we eat at home earlier we had a
secretary pardon I'm sure all something
different there we got different on tops
and we got what we call a twist very
good job Bungay on the horizon there we
good harvest and how to be sad some
antelopes that are similar to other
antelopes that we call top is very
particular this harvest definitely happy
was and fitting at that very top area of
wow we're going to be moving because I
need to get the sausages before it gets
dark
and as they do that we'll take you back
to Tristan
well you are back with me and we are
slowly bumbling down to Chitra Dam to go
and see what's happening at the dam we
need to go and see if there's any sign
of any of the pretend calls that's often
hang around here and just kind of
generally just take it easy for a while
until the sort of madness settles up
there and then we can go back again to
many corners of crazy up there so you
know how I have a phobia for cars I'll
try and avoid there as much as I can
when it comes to sort of that area and
so rather come and have a little look
that trip to dam and see what's
happening on this side of the world it's
always a good sight to come is off I
haven't been here in so long I don't
even know what it looks like really
anymore I can't actually remember the
last time I was sort of live from Jindra
dam and did any sort of segments of any
sort of description actually it's been a
long time anyway it's exactly it is
still a big puddle of water in fact it's
actually not as big as it should be it's
still quite low actually you can see the
island hasn't taken place sorry excuse
me I pick ups a little bit there so the
Lions have I mean there the island
hasn't taken place in and while I'm
seeing lines of maybe it's because I
heard lions just now and having an
absolute nightmare to talk the soft and
you know I don't know what's going on
I've been struggling to speak to anyone
really so it's been a bit tricky yes the
words get them out I need to do the word
exercises and I during the break before
we start our TV shows
but anyway hippos are everywhere no sign
of any of the practicals that are here
so I don't know if they've arrived or
maybe they're not going to come this
year which will be quite sad it's one of
the few places and in fact it's the only
place in the soybean sense that I had
know of that you can get a regular
sighting of them all used to be able to
get a regular sighting of them so it'll
be a bit sad if they don't come to this
area but nice to have the hippos they
busy bobbing about as they do I'd like
to kind of pop in the water and take it
very easy and especially on a day like
today I suppose it's not exactly bad
weather the water will probably be very
pleasant to be in has been fairly warm
during the middle part of the day and
it's not a slowly starting to kind of
cool down a bit to this bit of a breeze
and clouds that are blowing in but I
suppose being a hippo water in some
months is your best friend chakra dammed
it definitely has a lot of water to
still kind of gain and fill it up and
the fact that these islands are no
longer Islands are the really big one on
the rights means that it's still very
very low and it means a lot more water
until it's back to its normal sort of
state and that's obviously going to take
a bit of time but at least this process
has started it must have been very low
before the kind of rains arrived
recently and when you've got an expanse
of water like this the problem with it
is that is a lot of evaporation you get
a huge amount of wind that blows as well
as Sun and that causes this to kind of
dry out quite quickly so especially in
very hot temperatures now this is my
favourite little birds that we see a
Chitra are around though there's that
little three banded levers and remember
loss was last year the year before
actually I can't even remember now and
where we had the little tiny baby chicks
and the eggs that we found and so these
are all three abandoned clubbers or very
cool little birds I always love watching
them kind of move around and pick around
for insects no sign of any little ones
with them today but maybe their chicks
or somewhere here and we'll be able to
find them at some point scenic no no
fish eagles that I can see was scouting
about but they don't see any fish eagles
at all what I can see is a spoonful that
is sitting looks like a spindle has a
spindle face that's sitting on the top
of that tree so it looks like to be a
spindle that's sitting there but no fish
eagles that I can spot at this stage I'm
looking in the jackal berry that's off
to the downside looking in the dead
trees but no sign of where he likes
where they like to normally sit they
might be on the other side of the dam
somewhere they often do sit there's a
tree that's kind of in front of the last
rooms that they sometimes a death right
well we are you going to millibars on
chatter we'll amble and see what we can
find in the meantime they're back up
there to David who has been successful
and has found exactly what he was
looking for very good Tristan chitra
area is always a wonderful and very
productive area and I got a very hungry
gentleman here who at a quick look on
one of his left eyes I got he got an
injured left eye but that is not
stopping him from devouring this male
Buffalo that I was talking about I was
here yesterday I'm saying I do not have
to work very hard to come and trace this
wonderful setting and for those of you
who could be literally disturbed over
'scrimish by watching something like
this you may choose not to watch and
maybe do something different or switch
onto another channel or switch off and
maybe come back later but again this is
how things go here this is the chain
this is the food chain here in Africa
wilderness now this man belongs to the
old owner pikeville's he's the coolest
of bears I was talking about almost ooh
I do not know where the other one is I
just found this one feeding on this
particular
Buffalo male that was I think killed the
night before last I don't know why the
Gaza but definitely I was sure they're
not very fun look on his left high and I
think he he is injured even what's wrong
you got a scar there and he looks a
little bit blood bloody and you can see
he isn't opening it properly and I think
yeah it's a must have either he was and
if he got an infection or he was
involved in the fight because it looks
really infected it looks little bloody
it looks like it's got a scar so it
could be both it's an infection or it's
the infection would have come from a
scar because if you look at the very own
eyelids there exactly think even gay
it's bloody so maybe it's got a claw
back there it's got a teeth mark there
and of course in the process he was
wound and then because of the flies and
all that I should definitely get an
infection and I guess he was a proper
infection then both eyes would be
affected but it's going to be
investigated and find out what you know
could be happening the good news is this
cuts very resilient and they very
quickly recover from such infections
he was the infection of course if it's a
wound definitely it will come out of it
there's a particular coalition of Mayors
in Amara triangle that you call this
coffees and that's the main male iron in
that particular coalition and he got
such a huge scar on the eye and that's
how he was named disk office and of
course males every other few months
we'll definitely go for each other for
takeovers of Preds and when that happens
he's always sometimes life and death
it's not it's never walk over so there's
lots of clawing little of teeth in
sometimes they lose the eyes
giraffe rape young yes I mean personally
I'm thinking while this could make some
very nice ribs if we could do some
roasting you know it could be very nice
rib eye if someone could roast it for us
Julie you're saying this is the lion yes
and this is Mel and it belongs to a
coalition of our tumors that we call the
all-new pike it belongs to a coalition
of trimmers that we called hold on your
pack and definitely can tell if you see
the other one the male the the main is
maca and much longer than this one here
so this one sometimes we call him
blondie and when they compare the
characters of the other to this one here
is always a little bit Moody a little
bit between Moody and Grandpa there and
the other on his own is very cooperative
the times when he look at him he is like
what are you looking at me no
and I'm guessing chances are he might
have found the girls eating and he
pushed them out with the characters and
until he eats enough and some of the
lions have been known to eat up back to
20% of their body weight you would
imagine if this guy could be anything
250 kilos or 500 pounds or so he could
be eating almost 50 kilos almost going
to help pounds of meat in you know one
sitting I mean they eat locked lions and
that's why the end up going flat to be
able to adjust what we have written
slowly and surely also conserving their
energy remember I should have any
questions or any comments you may send
them using hashtag Safari Live or
Twitter we get lots of joy to hear from
you
boy did you rise do you want have a
change but it's crush there either way
he is very handsome
I mean comparing to the other one that I
think smart handsome than the other on
well gonna be waiting hopefully the
brother or the other pride male will be
coming around let's first go back to see
me
I can see that my pride as well as one
representative of the focus are now
resting but the Avoca is very much
worried I can see that he is trying to
judge something around here so they have
just been mating on the past 5-10
minutes while you away we have just
missed that action due to some technical
poor signal difficulties so here I can
see that tired at the moment and they
are just like that look at how beautiful
that mean is that is so charming
I'm not surprised why this female is
staying together with this beautiful
smiley maned male look at that this is
so amazing it is a gorgeous mainly you
can see that so the Lions they've got to
mate mostly every 15 minutes and they
are going to do this for about five to
six sometimes seven days or more and if
you can check if they do five to six
days in full after every 15 minutes it
means they can mate up to 250 times a
day
so now let's quickly cross over to
Tristan with a band not just with the
bird Sydney is a bird that is as
beautiful as your male line and could
rival it for good looks especially when
it sets amongst the greenery of that
weeping wattle to have that bright kind
of iridescent blue ring and that red
beak and white chest makes that wooden
Kingfisher looking as glorious as you
could ever imagine you see it's got
little pond there it's had a bit of a
dip in order to just clean itself up and
make sure that its feathers are all nice
and clean and looked after they often do
this and then people will think that
they're actually fishing and they're not
they basically are going there to
essentially clean their feathers out and
so they'll just drop into water soak
themselves a little bit and may have a
little bit of a bath and then they groom
themselves out and
sure that they are really well after
these guys are seriously beautiful but
we're not sitting here looking at them
just now I was thinking about a
Kingfisher that I saw in the Congo and
while we were there and it's got to be
one that's really kind of I suppose
rivals for me rivals these woodlands in
terms of just striking it and the reason
why is is I'll show you now I've just
got to try and find a picture of it if I
can hopefully I will be able to but they
they really have this seriously kind of
blue appearance to them they are
incredibly pretty birds the vibrant
vibrant vibrant blue right now I found
the picture but apparently Sydney's
still with mating pay I wonder if they
may be gonna make some will quickly send
a move to you and then I'll show you the
Kingfisher when you come back so you can
see that we just caught them by the
right time now but listen to the rich
words listen that was amazing you can
see that the female is losing all the
energy she can't even fight him back now
like the beginning a few days ago
whereby after the withdrawal of the male
Oh during the withdrawal she was turning
and scratched his head and tried to
fight back and he was also
italia' ting back so you can see this
too they are not gonna go far as they
are just mating after every 15 minutes
and more so they will be around here
look at her training now trying to fix
the copulatory genital passage as the
male it is equipped the male's copulate
er organ is equipped with quite a lot of
spikes which halves in order to scratch
the internal part of their female
and this was so lovely so you saw the
mail he was trying to grab the female
from the back that is normal this kind
of animals when they're still very young
moved from one place to another from one
den to the other by the females and when
the female grabs by the back he will see
they become lamb and he can be able
chicken be able to move them so what the
male is doing the same thing trying to
stabilize the female from grabbing hair
at the back now he's damn indeed she
must be exhausted
imagine this is happening after every 15
minutes as I indicated earlier 250 times
if this is happening in full consecutive
five days that is quite a huge
responsibility on both male and females
you can see that is trying to pick up
some of this information from the air
particles but he is also going to lie
down
he's not gonna stand there much longer
look at the body now you can see the
stomach is getting empty again he was so
full they just fed on a buffalo three
days ago but all the energy they are now
used in order for them to mate look at
it she wants to rest nicely I'm sure the
female you can see she's just relocating
apologies for the pole I'm just gonna
try and move a little bit but let me
wait until they're settled
you can see that she's even now moving
away she doesn't want to see him after
she she has been scratched by this male
during the withdrawal but she will come
back again and she will be the one to
approach him again and ask him again for
another action so now let's cross back
to Tristan and see how he's doing it
will happen again soon yeah when they
get into it they certainly don't hold
back
do you Lions and cats win they are
mating and so hopefully they will mate
once again for you guys but I was
talking about our Kingfisher so this is
the Kingfisher that I was talking about
it's called a shining blue Kingfisher
and you can see why it's called a
shining blue Kingfisher so it's got this
you're a decent dark blue on the sort of
back edge and in this light colored blue
that runs through the middle section
with an orange belly and it really is
striking now it doesn't look that great
in this picture as unfortunate the best
picture I could find because the life
there is quite dull but when we saw them
in the Congo we were going along one of
these little tributaries that goes out
of the BI and into the main river the
Laconia River I mean kind of going along
and then they flushed out and they
winter and sat on this branch and as
they kind of went out the Sun came out
and that color just went electric
electric blue it was incredible how
beautiful they were really really pretty
birds and we had looked for them for
days and days and days and so I was
super happy that we managed to find them
the other bird that actually occurs up
there funny enough that I forgot
completely about is another Kingfisher
that looks almost like our woodlands
it's called a blue-breasted Kingfisher
which and its call is actually quite
similar - which is quite interesting
they a very kind of funny-looking bird
I suppose actually closer towards a
mangrove Kingfisher than Earth in a
Woodlands but they are basically there
we go hold on I've found a picture David
give me two seconds I'm going to show
you so they they have a similar look to
the mangroves a Kingfisher that we see
here they've got that sort of black eye
strap it's a little bit similar as
opposed to the
Woodlands but you see the kind of blue
brace band that gives you that name blue
bracelet Kingfisher very very pretty
bird as well and they fly around and
they make this call very similar to the
woodland Kingfisher so scenic do they
all have the same call no and
unfortunately no I can't play the call
because I actually don't have the Congo
birds on my phone in terms of the bird
call so I have any other South African
ones and some of the Kenyan ones
unfortunately I wouldn't be able to play
that for you guys which is a shame
because I would like for you to hear it
funny enough talking about Kingfisher
calls and kingfishers and Congo the
other Kingfisher that we went to go and
see there that is also a very special
bird and in hangs around more in the
forest than any whales it's called a
chocolate backing fish air and the way
we found it was by listening to its call
and we were walking along one afternoon
and we were in a small group it was all
the boys that were together and we went
on this this epic walk through the
forest and it was just really to go and
see what we could find we weren't really
looking for anything we were just
whatever there was we would take it and
we were walking along walking along and
we heard this bird calling and one of
the guys that was in our group who's an
incredible birder and he said no it's a
chocolate black Kingfisher and and quite
a few of us hadn't seen one so he said
no we're gonna try and find it and
slowly but surely we tracked through
this forest this Kingfisher Colin avenge
me high up in the canopy about I'd say
25 to 30 metres up we've spotted these
chocolate packing fishes that we're
calling it was really tricky to see them
as a hippo that's displaying his best
that he can at the moment lots of head
shaking and big displays going on back
there but it was really nice to kind of
found the the kingfishers and to find it
in that way it was awesome and then
while we were sitting with the chocolate
back Kingfisher we then heard this
telltale call of a guinea fowl now they
it's not like here we commented guinea
fowls running around all over the place
the guinea fowls that are in the Congo
forest all very hard to find they run
around and the Congress is thick its
dense brush that you can't really see
what's going on at all and you just hear
this kind of can you
alcohol and it was the blue meanie file
this as the one that we heard calling
and it then eventually went through and
we could hear it calling hear it calling
couldn't see it and it was closed it was
within sort of five meters and we were
kind of like crawling through this
undergrowth to try and get a view of it
because the one guy that was with us was
trying to get a photos and a very good
birder that I was talking about a guy
called Adam he was trying to get a not
Adam that I normally talk about that
said in comments another Adam and so we
had to Adams on the trip I know very
very confusing and we had a Nicki and a
Vicki so it was you know cut a bit
tongue tied at times but anyway so we
were crawling through this undergrowth
and Adam really wanted a picture and
it's then kind of flew up this plume can
you fall and set on this perfect little
branch and a gap in the forest and there
was this beautiful kind of green
background and he managed to get a
picture of it which was absolutely
amazing and it was only there for about
a second before a few away and then I
was the only even the Columbus regards
of a guinea fowl in the in the days that
we were there and we walked that forest
from sunrise to sunset pretty much every
single day so it gives you an idea of
how lucky we were to actually see it so
very very special and birding in the
Congo was unbelievable there was so many
amazing things but these are hippos are
still having a bit of a play in the
background there's lots and lots of
bouncing around from some of the hippos
you can see some of the wake in the
background good we're gonna carry on
kind of milling about we'll see if we
can head off towards those lipids a
little bit later but in the meantime
we'll send you back across to David
who's in the Mara and still sitting I
think with his lions well the times as
guys when you go out we miss to see the
big mamas were the big animals and we
deal with smaller bunch of feathered
friends as we call him and this is one
of them and this one here is some sort
of vulture is a vulture other and it's
called a hooded vulture hooded vulture
and only here for one reason just wait
until these lions are going to give his
kill and she can sneak in and start
cleaning the Savannah as is the main job
we call them our garbage collectors but
they do such a wonderful job
so long as this male is here there's not
much she is going to do we RDSO a whole
bunch of them on top of a tree or on top
of a country and this guy must have hard
I don't know how many pounds maybe 50 60
70 pounds of meat and you can see how
now he is panting with a very big Betty
and all those flies in her tummy but he
is about what just about under one we
tell about three feet from the keel he
cannot see very far from it because they
know they cannot trust the vultures so
yeah that's about three feet more or
less in that yeah that can be very each
with all the flies there and this is one
of the reasons why all the flies when
they become a nuisance this friend had
been known to climb the sausage' trees
well he's gonna be here and I've been
waiting to see if his other brother will
come because you are in the sausage
republic now and the males that rule
this area are called the horned Anja
pike now from where we are the kitchen
is a quite a distance and they have a
different territory they have a
different the other coalition is of
three and the very close to the camp
such a long way from could be an hour
plus to the all our pride and that's how
we usually see the cute remains of three
there's one code in the half tail
there's another one called fun and
there's a third one now these two here
we have not been able to give them names
because I mean we call him the old owner
Pike but they don't have individual
names because we think they must have
overthrown Cape fully we all know too
Polly got a clip like on his nose and he
got two other youngsters and they formed
a coalition but we don't know where they
are
they could have gone to serengeti
tanzania
tonisha how are you and you'd like to
know the largest fred in tomorrow
number one tunisia and Amarra we got
over ten prides in tomorrow triangle
over ten I won't give them names to you
but I'll give you one particular one
here that we have because we have the
sausage bread now the
August is called the Halal of pride and
uncertainty sure you can see that after
me although our pride because we are
making a song between me and Bungay and
our vast will be
anyhow that particular pride has 16
members 1 6 that's pretty large pride
and we think there could be two new
additions in that pride because the
other day could be like 5 days ago I saw
one of the other females in that
particular pride and she looked big she
had a swollen belly went away and came
back after few days and I saw two
smaller Cubs with that particular female
so if there are 16 plus this 2 now we
got 18 so that would be the largest
pride in the Mara triangle
well the sausage of pride is trying to
catch up because they got five females
here without counting the male's that
come in and go in a pride will always
count the females and the youngsters and
they got three new Cubs one on you there
for three months old so that makes eight
and of the two other females here we've
got two that a pregnant one of them is
called kinky tail and we think or people
the viewers have been thinking she could
be carrying three so we might end up
with the eleven and if the other now
have another three we might have
fourteen who knows and they'll be
catching up very much with the hollows
who knows so we're just waiting to see
I've been hoping that these two girls in
his pride will give us you know new
bundles of joy with the beginning of the
year not yet and you know I think he's
out of my excitement that I'm thinking
she's late and he's still not do it
takes about 100 105 days to have the
caps so we'll see what happens maybe the
next few days but I usually do as much
as I can to sing around this area every
other day to see whether I'll surprise
myself with a new camp well that one
just to stand turn around and they'll
also turn around to South Africa to
Jamie
hello we are back up and running fingers
crossed
so hopefully the problems that we were
having with the vehicle have now been
sorted thanks to our amazing tech team
and we are well we are now doing every
single hyena den on Juma we've just I've
just checked all breeze road nothing
definitely not active they are
well that one tunnels actually
completely filled with dirt so they're
not in there so I'm going back to check
our well our assumption that they'd
actually moved from filaments cut line
the nice thing is it's nice and cool
this evening so there's a good chance
that they will actually wherever they
are they'll be there how's that for a
sentence wherever they are they'll be
there wherever the den is there's a good
chance the adults are there now because
it's it's cold weather so they're not
they're gonna be coming back to the Cubs
early I hope so we're gonna go and check
for them on scut line and then the one
just south of that and checked everybody
else of Gallagher I've checked him
boo-boo
I've checked so Tristan was gonna go
past Zoe's Hodder
but I mean they haven't used so Eastern
2015 the base my knowledge but you never
know
and then there's that den that when you
on Cheeta cut Ryan don't think they're
gonna be at that den though they were in
our camp last night so in fact all we
really need to do is up through the
night wait for them to come and visit us
and then follow them back although I
suspect its ribbon that's paying a
nightly visit to the camp she was always
her in the past that's what we should
have done last night who needs sleep we
should have stayed awake and followed
whichever hyena decided to come and
investigate our camp tracks all the way
through going up to people's doors
sniffing around the bathrooms obviously
holds some sort of fascination for them
someone's driven there that must be
interest yeah maybe they maybe they've
just become really hygienic they're
gonna go and use our showers okay we're
gonna continue the search off you pop
across to Sydney to see if his lines of
feeling amorous so look at how beautiful
that male is like you can see that now
it's time for them to rest so he's not
doing anything at the moment but all he
has been doing was just watching and
trying to investigate if there's any
other animal coming maybe he's treated a
little bit by the scent of the other
males from far so you can see the female
is just lying down flat behind those
bushes sometimes it can be very
difficult to see the Lions when they are
hiding behind these bodies they can be
so very come a flesh they can blend
easily with a surrounding
he's a very cute boy you can see but
evoke us as a correlation all the
members of that coalition they look very
beautiful if you look at this one has
got very beautiful mane the other one
has got very beautiful eyes
so now let's quickly cross over to
Kristin and see what is happening now
well indeed you all back with us and we
with one of my favorite things to follow
around at you to them is some of you
might remember from the times that I've
been at the dam I often try and find
these little guys and watch them go
about their business now this is for
those of you don't know it's called the
green backed heron or striated Heron is
also its other name and they run along
the edges and they look for fish and
what they'll do is they'll slowly kind
of move and they skulk about and then
they get into little stalk mode much
like a cat does and that's why I like
them I think they is so fascinating to
watch are you going to do a hunt for us
it'll be amazing if it does come one
little one so they age towards the water
and then they watching and they find a
little fish and they'll just kind of
dart forward and then they extend that
Nick now there Nick looks though they
don't have one it almost looks as though
they like Uncle Fester without a nick
but actually what they would do is shoot
this long Nick out and they'll kind of
stab into these fish and grab them and
then eat them and they're such fun to
watch actually hunting I thoroughly
enjoy watching these guys go about their
business and it can be a kind of quite
sort of end of your seat stuff when you
watch them sort of sneaking up and they
get themselves primed and almost like a
leopard that bum Wiggles a little bit
and in that head shoots forward it's
very cool to see now in the background
you might be hearing a few different
bird calls when there's a white-faced
whistling dog that's calling which I
always love that court always reminds me
that they it's summer around here so
there's the spoonball that's kind of
moving around now sorry I missed the
name I did get the question but I
as I missed the name I was not focused
too well d so d line
don't can you get to the hearing
quickly it looks like it's gonna go
hippos in the background sorry that I'm
making a bit of noise but D line no I'm
not sure if this is the smallest heron
in the world it's actually not as small
as it looks if it sits upright and has
its neck up it's actually quite big
yes hippos we hear you we can hear you
guys in the background it's okay it's
aged closer come on are you gonna shoot
your neck art there's too much noise
going on it's it's the head patient and
you wouldn't think you don't think that
they would be fishing there's cellos but
they are they trying to escape all the
predatory fish within the system so
especially things like the catfish that
swim around you know they'll eat all
these little tiny fish and so they try
and get right up into the shallows where
the catfish can't go and yes I mean this
hippos don't want to share the spotlight
today at all they every time we try and
show something they start huffing and
puffing and making all kinds of noise
isn't this cool though I think it's cool
I know that many of you just think that
there's a bird staring at water but it's
in the hunt now so it's trying to get
itself kind of positioned and it's
waiting there we go you see it's just
starts to twitch a little bit almost
shot art it's Nick now I'm lot of you
are singing The Addams Family song in
reference to my Uncle Fester
kind of comment in the fact that this
has got no neck it doesn't quite look
like Uncle Fester it's a pretty bird but
it's definitely kind of has that same
build
doesn't it it's all round with very
small little legs and suppose if Uncle
Fester had a beak there would be and a
wig on they would have a similar thing
I'm sure the spirit doesn't like being
called Uncle Fester and but it's too
busy hunting for it to really care about
what I've got to say about life anyway a
little twitch again I think it's waiting
for as the fish kind of get a little
closer it's just gonna kind of I suppose
it's got to be the right moment every
single time I don't know the foam is
ruined it you see the foam on the edge
of the water has ruined its hands it
took on straight over the top where it
was
and maybe that spook the fish fish don't
like when things kind of go over the top
of them they get quite nervous and so
knowing the foam on the edge of the
water sorry little hearin has that
disturbed everything always waiting on
the croc is now chasing something as
well so the croc went after something I
don't know what it was but it just went
bolting they look you see what's it
caught
what's hunting fish as well you see that
do you see the fish jumping that is
crazy so the Crocs here hunt fish all
the time and they'll go after them
regula and at the moment they're in the
favorite little hunting spot is
unfortunately nots got any water in it
and so maybe that's why they're trying
to hunt on the edge here when they see
maybe catfish pushing up towards the the
shallows and the other fish kind of
bubbling they rush in the other
crocodile couldn't care at all it was
kind of unfazed by what just happened
but that croc rushed in very very
quickly
to try and see and it was cool to see
the fish kind of jumping out of the
water and you'll see when they hunt like
that every now and then it is very cool
well nothing you say bad day to be a
fish but to both these predators have
been outsmarted at this point so the
herons got nothing the crocodiles got
nothing and so you know so far the fish
two predators
zero at the stage which if you're if I
was a fish our take those odds any day
of the week if I'm honest I'd rather be
on those odds than the other way around
hippos again you just hear the wind is
also getting up a little bit anyway
unfortunately our Heron is moved off now
because of the foam so it's not hunting
him also we gonna carry on we leave chat
with them and probably now in the
meantime though back to the Masai Mara
do David I think he's still sitting with
the Lions and I hope that they'll get up
and do something soon
that could be such an exciting hunting
of a crop trying to get some sort of
fish not sure what fish she would get
either you know mud fish or a catfish
but anyhow we are coming to my golden
hour or my golden moment and that's the
western horizon see Sun is slowly
pushing away heading home
and that could be marking the end of
another lovely day here in the Mara but
as the Sun goes who will be getting
other excitement because as we were
watching earlier we had this particular
one here that has been feeding on this
Buffalo and in the particular girl she's
in the bushes there I saw another male
just chewed up and he must have sat down
somewhere there and you remember I was
talking of a coalition of two males that
we call the Olin Danya Pike that we
think are now in charge of these girls
here that you call the sausage of pride
he just went flat on the cross there to
take long for him to come and I guess
he'll come here that's why strategically
I have not moved from Who I am because I
know also the females will show up and
even if they don't this is where the
food is this is where the key is
chances are they must all come for food
at one point to have some dinner before
it gets done so what we're gonna do
we'll just go back to or Mel will show
you how flat he is for couple of minutes
and then maybe decide to move away and
see whether we could be lucky to find
out where those cars are because I'm
still very convinced they're not very
far and if anywhere they moved they must
have gone can you see now that if you
look carefully let's go back get that
grass that's the ball I'm talking about
just put his head up and that's the
other member of the all enduring a
pioneer and hawai he's not coming here I
do not know and yes did you hear me
please come over come junior-brother
are you a little bit and you need to
have to eat together and maybe see how
the one that just
there with the kill will react as soon
as he gets here working very slowly
of confidence with a number flick of
tails for lions when they walk through
the Savannah grass of the Amara triangle
and remember ladies and gentlemen should
you have any questions or comments you
may send them through hashtag safari
live on Twitter
we love interacting with you in real
time as you can see the Bell you saw
this oops can't even walk you are too
full I was just about to say the belly
of this and then he just confirmed what
I wanted to say it's too heavy
too full and it took a few steps stop
and rest and yes you have every right
and being that lazy I'm not sure I
really want to go why you are I'm going
to wait for you hidden till you come
let's find out or compare it's lazy boy
who head in the cross to Sydney's dams
one space available so you can see that
our responsible male of this female is
now lying down and I can promise you now
is getting cold a little bit maybe they
might wake up and move but they're not
gonna move far as we have been here for
quite a while now they have only moved
for a distance which is less than 60
meters and 60 meters they have already
mated three times so already they have
mated three times so which means if we
can add more more meters away from where
they are they are still going to do the
same I saw that every time the female is
interested to move the male is going
along side hair and try to buy chair on
the ear pushing her to go down and after
doing that she's lying down on the
ground and things are happening so
yesterday and few days ago the female is
the one who was doing the dance now the
female is not doing the dance in Lord
the male is the one who is pushing the
female in order to mate
so you can see that this armors
Cree's what a lovely question and that
question is one of those very much
important questions today when having
this kind of a sighting if another male
comes here whether big or small
this male we're seeing Langdon here is
going to stand up and defend the female
whether the lion is just passing by or
is coming with the intentions of taking
over there's going to be a very big
fight this male lion doesn't want any
other male to come near this female we
are going to see a very big fight which
can be vicious you can see he's got
quite a lot of scratch marks already and
I can promise you I don't think this any
other male which will be able to
challenge him here at this stage from
what they have witnessed when he was
challenging others but yeah that does
not mean if another male comes here is
not going to win the fight the thing is
he has been mating consecutively in a
very short space I'm sure he doesn't
have much strength to challenge another
fresh male who is coming from feeding
I can see how his sleeping is looking
very much tired and the females don't
mind to mate with other males so she can
be able to mate with several males from
the very same oestrus occur if the males
are competing and some are winning some
are losing she will just consider the
winners
so now let's quickly cross over to Jamie
and hear how she's doing okay so this is
the last active den site that we know of
it's the one just south of Philemon scut
line and there's a track or two in the
mud and I've noticed while I've been
sitting here there are flies around the
entrance to the den site itself I think
there is a possibility that they're
still here something a little bit
scuffed about that although that could
have just been washed in it's really
difficult to tell and I'm not gonna go
stick my head down the entrance-hall if
there's potential for Cubs in there it
would terrify the absolute daylights out
of them so we're not we're not going to
do that we're not going to terrorize
tiny hyena Cubs that's a little bit
unfair and so I think it is that we have
to move on and just see what else we can
find I was hoping I've just been sitting
here for a minute
just to wait and see whether or not
there's any sign of movement or sound
from within the den but nothing I don't
know I don't know I don't know where
they've gone it's going to be very
difficult to find them if they haven't
gone to one of their regular dens
because it's so thick now that's not the
other different
oh well onwards we go we're going to go
back and we're going to go around to
where Tristan says he might have seen or
Dave might have seen sorry Craig
watch out might have seen a colored spot
on a termite mound you know so we really
clutching at straws here when Tristan
was racing to husana you never know this
routes to treehouse Dam and we'll see
from here all right while we do that
let's send you across to the man who let
us know himself and find out if he
thinks we'll get lucky with it well good
luck
Jamie David only told me about the
colored spot a while ago and and he's
not when we were actually then so I
couldn't look and see what it was I hope
it wasn't that cheetah that we missed
completely but he kind of just came past
quickly where hassanis kill was hoping
you might be in the tree he's not in the
tree unfortunately we can't see where he
is
so we're just going to carry on towards
Tandy and Columba back into that
sighting now that we can this little
freak marks though always like seeing
hosannas little pug marks you can see
them in the road very good
very cool it's got nice feet doesn't he
yes we like a young lad he's very cool
animal and hopefully he's going to spend
some time coming towards Tandy and
Columba tonight it will be very very
nice just now so we're going to
hopefully get a view of him we're gonna
head off like I say hopefully have them
on the kind of unkillable
I don't know I heard something about
Tandy moving but I didn't really kind of
listen I was too busy talking about
hippos and stuff and I
at that stage missing what was happening
and so we'll just check and see I'm
hoping that she hasn't disappeared and
that she's still here we surprised when
she left maybe she's going to go and see
what her delinquent half-brother he's
been up to and what he's doing so close
to her you know how she loves to have
other lipids around Tandy is always so
grumpy when it comes to other deputies
was he seeing Raleigh and snarly so
maybe she's going to end sort her
half-brother Hart right
yes it looks like Tandy's gone north of
the road and little clamors on this side
of the road missed all vehicles yeah but
these are the last two vehicles then
kind of haven't thought about coming and
so should be okay just to kind of slide
in here somewhere and to be able to see
not very much given the way everybody's
part is going to be able tricky
unfortunately sorry David
and it's unfortunately what visual we
have so we're gonna try and kind of wait
and see if Tunya will move and come back
or if little clamber will also kind of
give us a better view of what's going on
but at least we still can see her a
little bit kind of feeding on her
carcass and maybe it's in quite a bit of
it already which is interesting because
I've received we know that yesterday
morning they were still finishing off a
kill in Torchwood and so they must have
been grazing this since last night so it
must have happened during the course of
the night or maybe early hours of this
morning and they've eaten as much as
they can out of it but it's interesting
that they've kind of as little as there
is left but right now Columbia is
feeding and she's grown and gotten big
uns almost at that age where to me
difficult to call it a cabin that we can
call it kind of really I suppose but it
sounds like David's up in the Mara well
he's found ones that are Cubs and they
are not spotty but rather Tony I think
Solomon could be going to about a year
now in sense of age but now my Cubs here
are four months and three months and
they just got to the darling table
well number one you may notice the
lighting has changed a little bit
because it has got a little bit darker
here in Kenya in the Mara Triangle and
now we are using an infrared camera
pretty special camera it's got some
invisible lights to the animals but we
can see them very well so going dark
here and you have changed to infrared
which does not show the actual colors
that you know of that
familiar with you of the Lions and of
course the grass
this grass is very green because of the
rain so I've been having and now the
other male that just came in and another
female came in and the three Cubs came
in so I think my bet was fair and middle
of sales yeah how are you and you'd like
to know what's the gas station period
all flights is about a hundred a hundred
five days so shortly after three months
you'll get a mother lower a lioness
popping up either one or two or three
cubs certain cases we have seen four
cups it's about an average of a hundred
to a hundred and five days now this
one's the two pair the two sets of
curves here two of the same age about
four months and this one which is that
particular on there that's about three
months old
and they have different mothers I do not
know where they were and I told Bungay
the best thing to do is to stick here
and stay put and wait so long as there's
food they will come back I never had
gone for a drink and because this scale
is barely 48 I was old this is still a
lot of meat in it and you can see that
smaller guy they're trying to climb on
top not sure whether he knows how big
those ribs are or maybe what his parents
went through Jennifer cobby's yes I'm
very happy Jennifer you enjoying all
these and a strength compared the size
of that big male lion there in that
smaller camera in the Buffalo looking at
those two sizes in proportionality to
the small cub no shots going on just
listen for a second
no the animal that just came in they
have formed a very formidable coalition
and these two will call in the hold on
your pack and you think they are the
ones that over to you Rick pulley and
the two youngsters see the caps under
the male there you know here all day
grumbling they're you know the vocals
sound they're making and because I've
always thought lanes
do not have very good table manners as
they eat
this is a great wedding and I think my
day has been made today and any time I
say you see lion season was a great day
and I haven't seen spirits for a couple
of days I don't know where they are been
but I think they're back in action
the Cubs seems to be doing pretty well
and talking of captures reminded me of -
lamba in Juba very nice Lepidus to see
her coming or taking ship and maybe
she'll be in the future
you know queen of that area once her
mother's gone yes Laura it's a nice way
for us over the Slayers to end up
getting the Edina thank you so much
Laura for such a nice comment and I'm
just feeling you know tempted to get
hungry well well done Jamie
well done Sydney water on trees and
South Africa Lions - lamba and also well
done myself here with Bungay for having
gotten the sausage - pride and it's such
a good way to end a drive so I want to
thank all of you for having been onboard
and I'm sure you all know we'll be out
here again tomorrow morning to bring you
such glorious wilderness thank you so
very much and from the African
wilderness and more so tomorrow triangle
we are saying thank you again and
goodbye
you